trust only your own leaders trust them
and ey question everything
be wise question everything question
your leaders don't follow people blindly
you can put your trust in them sure but
at the same time they have to be wise
be wise to question them he wants to try
to understand their decisions be wise
enough to disobey them should they
choose to lead in a manner that is
detrimental to the mission and to common
sense and you don't want you gotta be
wise not just about cheerleaders
biography assume to understand him to be
born which you do by watching and by
observing them and by listening that
then you know you spend a lot of time on
output we are sending all the time we
are talking all the time they are
putting information out by the time that
we went to the overseas vote a little
bit more learned of the similar reforms
learn to capture and absorb and utilize
what other people revealed and when you
do that you garner a better
understanding of them of yourself of you
team of your enemy or the nature of the
battle itself and the nature of humans
itself so listen and learn and
understand so that you can become wise
politically become wise
then you can win
[Music]